In the web, over the last five or 10 years, we've kind of established a new type of partner
and those are traffic partners
In a traffic partner, we have long-term agreements with other companies
that deliver predictable levels of customers to our website.
How do we do that?
Well, these are sometimes cross referral or swapping deals.
We pay another company may be on a per-referral basis
and our partners, our traffic partners, drive traffic using text links, on-site promotions
and ads on their site and sometimes, we might even exchange email list
and other data with these partners.
So, if you're on the web, traffic partner is a virtual channel partner
that simply doesn't exist in the physical world.